always exciting when we get to see this
left-hander on the mound wade miley
works quick and boy has he been
impressive this year
here's odubal when o'doodle swings at
the first pitch and hits it out towards
shallow right field castiano's lumbers
over and it bounces
in fair territory and oh doubles going
to get to second base
harper 11 homer's 21 knocked in it's
been a sea of solo homers and the first
pitch taps it to motto who fires home
and the tag on the poor slide collapsing
to his knees herrera left himself dead
to right short of the play
he was shocked that vado went home
spencer's numbers four starts one two
with a five point five nine era overall
swagger to miss
it's a slider again so he picks up a
strikeout and it's a one two three
bottom of the first inning solid start
suarez nice pick ranging left one foot
at off angle
wow
two balls and no strikes
andrew hitting 174 with a home run nine
runs batted in
and he pulls that one to left field and
that's going to be a base hit it's his
first hit at great american ballpark and
for the phillies it's going to be their
second extra base hit of the night
[Applause]
0-2
swing into this struck him out
first cave for miley
[Applause]
they get better as the game goes on you
put them in the stretch put a little
pressure on them
it changes in a hurry two twos whacked
to center field now to get down for a
base hit it goes off of herrera suarez's
turn at first but he'll hold on it
didn't kick too far away from the philly
center fielder but you could see that
sun is blinding in center field
barnhart well hit the vacated second
base slot suarez slows in second as
harper gathers it right back-to-back
two-out singles
swing and the mess wade miley second k
makes quick work of hoskins
first pitch to the gap in right center
down base hit miley through second the
ball just now hits base of the wall
gathered by herrera stop sign third
throw in oh they might have had a chance
j.r house stop sign for wade miley you
don't want to injure your pitcher
winker smashes a double to the gap i
think he might have scored there
it's only one out in the inning you got
your best hitter up castianos will step
to the plate
[Applause]
just beyond the outstretched glove of
torreyas miley scores and removes the
helmet furious wave is on for winker the
cutchen throw from left to the plate
winker slides in save two runs single by
castellanos and the reds lead two to
nothing
swinging to miss 93 up and suarez
strikes out side is retired the reds
though do strike they get a two-run
single by castianos
there's a liner out towards center field
that'll be in for base hit for harper
so that's the third hit for the phillies
they get the lead off batterer board for
the second time
yeah but so that'll bring up alec baum
who grounded out his first time up
he lines one out toward left center
field that'll be in for a base hit it's
going to the bullpen harper's heading to
third he's being waved home by dusty
watson and he's going to wind up scoring
that's an rbi double for alec ball and
the phillies are on the board it's a 2-1
ball game and with two on and nobody out
ronald torreira is coming up
reyes grounds one towards short they're
gonna go to second for one and that's
all they'll get a runal score it's a 2-2
game
inside throw to second base to get
freeman and he is out as he went off the
bag
luke williams stayed with the tag
swigger to miss
huskin strikes out so he's hold for
three
what out here in the fifth
two men aboard here's attic baum
and the line drive out toward left
center field that'll be in for a base
hit akiyama plays it cautiously herrera
is going to score it's an rbi single for
alec bowman the phillies take the lead
here at the top of the fifth inning
that'll load the bases up ronald torrez
who had an rbi his last time up
he pulls that one on the ground toward
third suarez to second williams beat it
and a run scores it's four to two
phillies
swing into this
miley goes fastball and gets knapped to
strike out
swinging to miss he lost his bad
and falter picks up his third strikeout
[Applause]
andrew wants it down and away
swag and a miss he did go up
and castianos is the fourth strikeout
victim of the night for belly falter
swinging a miss
threw him another slider and that's his
fifth strikeout
two outs here in the sixth inning
got him
he got two strikeouts in this hitting
with his slider he has six strikeouts
overall
kelly falter's done a heck of a job
foul tips strike three book and k's for
hembree
he strands the two out walk
we stretch
reds need a couple of runs
and here it is major league debut alejo
lopez listen to this crowd major league
debut for lopez he hits for freeman
first pitch broken back little blooper
down welcome to the show eleno lopez a
base knock on his first pitch
so belly falter is done
give him a
start of the game so far i mean that was
impressive walter goes four innings
allows two hits
swinging a miss 97 up in the zone and
india went fishing this is a man who
deserves to be in the mvp conversation
and he has often shined brightest in the
biggest spots bases loaded down two
oh one
in the air center field stumbled start
for herrera strikes back
gone
a grand slam
believe in nick castiano's
red six
phillies four
[Applause]
kyle farmer
first plate appearance today for former
bunt drop down
pitcher bobble
throw to first off
open door for suarez he comes home the
wave is on for stevenson harper and
right throws to the plate cut off safe
slide on the left hip for stevenson 8-4
reds batter runner farmer to second
two runs have scored farmers at second
hard grab ball terrain is hard range
can't handle office glove former green
light shallow center herrera india turns
it holds farmer scores the route is on
seven unanswered late by the reds it's
nine to four
and that will bring up nick castianos
well hit to left that's down basin india
storms through second ball gathered by
mccutcheon wave is on for india relay by
the phillies to the plate helmet free
and along slot save backside casting
almost to third he has driven in seven
runs
and the reds are rolling the phillies
10-4 in the 8th
and now joey bono
down and away gets away castellanos can
jog home he scores
11-4
[Applause]
[Music]
payoff
bottle unloads deep right center
foothill
rbi 999.
2-2 little dribbler osich flies off the
hill spins throws
ball game reds
double-digit runs
in the seventh and eighth
and they obliterate philadelphia 12-4